our vice president
our vice president kamala harris
has just attempted to explain
economics economics specifically with
regard to jamaica please tell me if you
can decipher this
we also recognize just as it has been in
the united states for jamaica one of the
issues that has been presented as an
issue that is economic in the way of its
impact has been the pandemic
so to that end we are announcing today
also that we will assist jamaica in
covid recovery um by assisting in terms
of the recovery efforts in jamaica that
have been essential to i believe what is
necessary to strengthen not only
the the issue of public health but also
the economy
ben
ben
why did you not pack the bong in the
travel kit so that i could understand
what the vice president had to say
why this is so unprofessional i have a
kamala bong
in my desk for a reason because when she
comes out and she says things like the
economic recovery is
is designed for the recovery of
in jamaica and especially for the
economy
and
we must do what we've been doing and the
time to do what we do is now to be doing
i have the bang so that i can try to
understand what the vice president is
saying but now i can't frankly i
probably couldn't
even with the bong right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles do you know what i had for
dinner
unfortunately i've been on the road this
week you know i had for dinner last week
i had delicious burgers from good
ranchers i love all their stuff from
good ranchers but the burgers are my
absolute favorite you know what kind of
burgers i had wagyu burgers that's right
high and juicy delicious
sometimes i grill it this was made in
the pan even more i just love these guys
and then i did actually right before i
flew out here we had good ranchers new
york strip steaks which were marvelous
they were absolutely marvelous the
quality of this meat is through the roof
and then the prices are shocking the
prices are so
inexpensive especially with inflation
now driving our food costs up through
the roof and then all of their meat
comes from america unlike the stuff
you're getting in the grocery store
sometimes 85 of that meat is not
actually made in america even if it says
it is
on every single aspect of your meat
consumption good ranchers is giving you
exactly what you want they're just
phenomenal
you can get a 30 discount right now on
prime steaks and better than organic
chicken the chicken's delicious i go to
goodranchers.com
save on the quality you've been looking
for take the guesswork out of the
grocery store save a ton of money right
now
make your meat consumption
inflation-proof you can subscribe if you
want right now and you're locked into
your price for life which is completely
insane go to goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles get your box of
100 american meat 30 bucks in savings
combat inflation with american meat
delivered i'm glad you like that clip
now please subscribe
ring that bell get the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind and
you can also check out fouchy unmasked
that's my three-part docu-series on that
little jerk dr fauci you can get that at
dailywire.com we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you